one time at LAX I had a gr of coke and I
had to fly back to Jersey so I put it in
my sock they'll never think of that yeah
and when I got to Jersey it was gone it
was evaporated from the heat of my feet
swe it into your foot what a
ripoff yeah what other places would you
smuggle drugs into we opened for Molly
Crew in Russia I asked the Russian road
crew and this one Russian dude goes oh
comrade yes you wait right there and I
have these pointy white boots and I put
them right in the toe man and I walked
through the airport like that the first
Russian metal show ah this is the one
where they were sober yeah were they
really sober
no they would have the world believe
that they recorded do Feelgood all
completely sober and for me as a kid and
what made me love mly crew like I had to
boycott that
album well I can tell you you can listen
to it